mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait est très
lent mais du temps pour porter une paire
de jumelles à monsieur du snob
j'attends julie pour lui faire une farce
parce qu'elle n'a pas confiance en moi
la voilà casimir vient voir j'en ai
profité pour apporter tout ce qu'il
fallait pour te préparer un super
gloubiboulga qu'est ce qui a bien vite
te cacher pourquoi nous sommes
surveillés surveiller ouais
où ça justement je ne sais pas hobo
casimir si c'est une farce à je ne la
trouve pas bonne du tout et julie j'ai
appris que monsieur du snob avait
commandé des jumelles pour te surveiller
toi et françois pour voir si vous êtes
gentil avec les enfants c'est quand même
le président de l'afld est de l'île
on écoute classé mire c'est impossible
comment on mode et ça crie ça pour toi
pour te rendre service un easy tu ne me
crois pas tant pis bon jeu viendra
chercher mon club iboga plus tard salut
salut casimir
[Musique]
enfin je chope robes laisser influencer
par les les bêtises de casimir et puis
et puis monsieur du snob et m e chargé
de l'amu temps pour l'oubli bulls a
alors ils risquent pas de l'observer au
plus frais pas quelque chose de si mal
c'est curieux j j'ai cru entendre un
bruit ça nous est mon imaginaire sur pie
travail
qu'est-ce que je suis bête bon eh ben je
vais faire mais je vais ouvrir le casse
complètement
c'est bizarre j'ai l'impression que
quelqu'un qui me regardent
monsieur du slam
si vous voyez quelque chose à vous
voulez dit monsieur du slam
monsieur du snob vous êtes là monsieur
dis shalom
je sais que vous êtes là alors sortez de
derrière les arbres complètement elliott
moi tu dis au sacré sûr je suis très
gentil avec les enfants se trouvent tout
autant que vous pouvez la reporter à les
porter
j'espère qu'il y aura donné une leçon
même temps à ma famille à mon temps à me
comprends pas mon âme ça va je magasine
tu avais raison
un quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya messieurs du
jeune homme obtient avait vraiment ça
c'est vraiment prendront alors moi je
trouve pas ça amusant du tout tu sais
enfin je lui qui n'a pas pompé c'était
une blague a eu un break mais oui c'est
une farce que je te disais que j'étais
faite parce que tu n'avais pas confiance
en moi monsieur du jeune homme ne t'a
jamais observée avec ses jumelles et moi
qui lui ai donné une gifle juge yvan
extraordinaire un bravo jaurès j'aurais
vraiment aimé être là pour voir ça
est-ce que tu as préparé mon
gloubiboulga mes péchés pack pas les
gifler sais pas
faire confiance
karimi tel est pris qui croyait prendre